despite push back from the White House
Texas governor Greg Abbott is ramping up
border enforcement and it appears
illegal immigrants are getting the
message and are instead heading to other
border states CBP sources tell Fox News
that over the last week of January
border patrol apprehended over 32,000
illegal immigrants and more than 71 thou
71% of those apprehensions are now in
Arizona and California so here to react
as pinol County Arizona sheriff and US
Senate candidate Mark Lamb uh Sheriff
Lam uh let's talk about these numbers
let's talk about the shift why why is uh
the focus of illegal immigration moving
from Texas to Arizona and California
look the cartels are a business they're
always going to push towards the path of
lease resistance and if so if Texas is
putting up resistance you're going to
see more flow towards Arizona please
plus people are watching the news too
even the people that are trying to come
here illegally and so if they think
Arizona is a better opportunity that's
where they're going to go that's why
we've seen a 30% increase over the the
last few weeks down in the Tucson sector
alone yeah let's take a look uh this is
back in Texas Eagle H Eagle Pass
apprehensions in December
71,000 in January down to 16,000 that's
there there's your
76% drop in in one month so Sheriff it
tell me is it simply like squeezing a
balloon is it is it you know you get a
little bit of enforcement in Texas and
the cartel shifts to Arizona and
California or is it actually a different
flow do you get a different illegal
immigrant out West than you would say in
Texas yeah on the Tucson sector we're
going to typically get those people
trying to avoid detection the majority
of what we get in Tucson sector are
people dressed in camouflage clothes
carpet shoes people that the cartels are
trying to keep from law enforcement
finding we also get the flow of people
from Africa and Syria and China and
those people come over and claim false
Asylum make false Asylum claims but
that's why Tucson sector also leads the
way in Goda ways is because we do have
that piece of people that are coming
with the border patrol trying to avoid
uh detection by border patrol and by us
whereas in Texas it was more typified by
what type of illegal immigration right
that's right no what type is it is it
more Central American or yeah you're
going to get a little bit of everything
but you're going to get the people
coming over and just saying hey look I I
claim Asylum so they're give UPS that's
what we call layups or give UPS what we
get out in Tucson sector are people that
are actually trying to get away that's
why Tucson sector no matter what the
flow is in Texas always leads the way in
Goda ways what about in in the style and
and path not just who it is but how it
is they they they illegally immigrate
you know uh in in and I know you're
speaking directly to Tucson which you
have direct experience with we're also
talking about a growth in California I
mean is this I I've been with you it's
it's much more rural it's mountainous
but uh what about tunnels and and that
type of situation versus what you would
see in Texas where it seems to be coming
a lot through ports of Entry
yeah your tunnels are going to be right
there closer to the to the cities like
nogalas you're going to see those around
there you're going to see a lot more
just rural Crossings out in the middle
of nowhere you know we uh I sent my son
down to an area that was about an hour
away from anything and there was a
fullon camp obviously the NOS were there
full force giving them water and food
and giving them a soft Landing spending
our T tax dollars on on aiding and a
betting this illegal activity but they
were far from anything and they were all
from uh Sudan from Africa from Syria
from Middle Eastern countries so there's
a lot more remote Crossings when you get
out into Arizona and it is very tough
terrain look we were just on uh we did
three rescues I think yesterday alone
the majority of my my my helicopter fuel
and all those things the resources we
use to help border patrol are expended
on re on rescues out in the mountains
well sherff far be it for me to pretend
more familiarity than we actually have
together but I'm going to say it that's
a goodlooking you got on this morning
than I don't know if it's new but the
shape and the color that's good you
nailed it I appreciate it as you're
running I got I'm running for set now
he's running for office and look at that
hat he got the right hat I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis